hey guys and welcome to in two minutes
now it's time to sound the news klaxon
ah there we go because there's a
brand-new game studio opening and you
know we're so used to hearing about them
getting it but it's a pleasant surprise
when a new one pops up especially one
that's got his bigger name as Jade
Raymond attached to it the former he was
our first announced on Monday that she
was partnering with the a and has
founded a new studio called motive which
got me thinking that's a really great
move for her it's a great thing for EA
and it's a great thing for us the gamers
so here's why jade is a renowned figure
in the games industry and has worked in
a variety of roles over a number of
years starting as a programmer at Sony
she shifted focus to become a producer
on the sims online before moving to
Ubisoft to become a producer on the
original Assassin's Creed and exec
producer on it's critically acclaimed
sequel following that she went on to
become the managing director of Ubisoft
Toronto studio which led development on
Splinter Cell blacklist and contributed
to various Assassin's Creed titles
rainbow sticks and far cry it's Lea she
has plenty of experience managing
blockbuster franchises and delivering
high-quality triple-a games but since
leaving you basalt in October last year
she's broaden her horizons and worked
the whole host of indie studios so she's
clearly got some ideas beyond running
along rooftops and hiding in the dark in
fact in her first EA blog post not only
does jade use the word I dating idea
ting however you say it it's ten points
in scrabble if you're wondering she also
mentions that her studio will be working
on new IP so armed with her management
skills of blockbuster triple a project
coupled with her insight into how
smaller indie studios nurture
interesting new ideas her fresh start at
EA is an incredibly exciting prospect
for the publisher and for us EA is
reestablishing itself as a gamer first
company and it's doing a respectable job
but let's face it for the past few years
EA has still leaned heavily on sequels
sports games and turning everything into
a big shootie extravaganza but ea's next
line up of games is showing some signs
of change
mixed its usual lot such as FIFA and
other sports ball titles it's also
backing the critical darling but
commercial air Mirror's Edge a meanwhile
the adorable platform unravel got a
significant amount of stage time at this
year's e3 so the fact that motive is
pitching itself as a creative driven
team and not one that will pick up
sequels is a great thing for all of us
ea's perceived public image may not be
the greatest but this new balance of
releasing fan favorites while actively
investing in different concepts in new
IP could mean that EA is the first major
publisher to find that ideal balance
between new and old and despite me
saying all of that ea's biggest game
this year is dolls however with
Raymond's new studio dedicated to
working on original ideas and with EA
showing signs of backing more
unconventional projects the future for
the publisher is looking less
predictable and when was the last time
you could say that about a major
publisher so while it's a little
premature to get excited about the
quality of games that are going to be
coming out of motive I'm really
optimistic for their placement with an
EA structure and they're in the same
building as the Mass Effect Andromeda
guys so I'm really hoping that something
magical comes out of there anyway what
do you think do you agree do you
disagree do you not care at all let me
know in the comments section below
that's all I've got for you this week be
sure to catch me on Twitter at Lucy
James games I'll see you next time